let's take a look at what's going on to
the au reaction first to the oil
inventory report what do the supply
fundamentals look like right now there's
a lot of oil around we're absolutely
swimming and crude in the US but there's
a lot of dynamics today it's a very
volatile market and some things that
actually caused prices to bounce rather
than react really to the crude inventory
build so we have a we have a weaker
dollar in the physical markets gasoline
is strong some of the other physical
crude grades such as LLS on a gulf coast
or are strong and you also have things
like a Yemen and anytime you see
headlines that you know the Saudis are
massing troops on the border something
like that even though we don't think
anything is imminent there to brand the
president leaving the country exactly
and that gets the market very twitchy
how desperate is the market to store all
right now well Cushing is very tight and
is getting very full so there's
definitely an issue there and it could
get worse in in the coming weeks and
that's why we're seeing again with the
exception of days like today big picture
we do expect for the next two to four
weeks that we see continuing pressure on
the front of the WTI curve Mike there's
no uniform standard on tank space the
EIA does not quantify it since operators
they are at liberty to set their own
levels of contingency do we really know
how close to full we are well actually I
a does put out some pretty good numbers
just twice a year and they don't update
it every week every month but what if
you look at what they're saying there's
actually a fair amount accrued in the
u.s. pace for storing crude in the u.s.
outside of cushing so again and you can
say to the same thing pretty much for
the rest of the world so Cushing there's
an issue but we don't actually think
that were really imminently bumping up
against constraints in the rest of the
world or in the rest of the u.s. your
colleague a lame but kasbah is so she
ate a general set of strategy and global
asset allocation he said in a report
this week the next few months will be in
his words detrimental for oil how
so well big picture in the second
quarter we expect huge global stock
bills to the tune 1.9 million barrels a
day and that's bearish any way you slice
it whether it's in the US or Europe or
Asia whether its crude or products
onshore offshore any way you slice it
it's a big number and that's going to be
bearish but in the coming weeks I think
the worst of the downward pressure
starts to shift from wti over to Brent
because in the u.s. remember we're
almost at a refinery maintenance season
so yeah so crude runs refinery demand in
other words starts to go up in April so
that's why I think the pressure actually
starts to shift over to brent oil is
down eleven percent from this year's
peak in February what's good what's that
going to mean for OPEC when it meets in
June not only means anything bro Peck I
think OPEC stays the course I think
Saudi Arabia and there you know Gulf
Arab allies are just going to let this
thing continue in other words let the
market set the price and they're not
going to actively try to manage supply
speaking of supply the rise in
production how is this making the global
supply glut worse well because so
because the guts of the issue is US
shale oil as you know and really we've
seen no impact on shale production
despite rig counts being down by almost
half you surprised by that the rig count
down by that much and there doesn't seem
to be any interruption what we knew
there was going to be a time lag I'm a
little surprised stepping back and how
long it's taken but there's actually
something in today's report which is
interesting week to week production for
the lower 48 states in the US which of
course is where shale oil is you know
it's actually flat and if you and some
of the reports that the EIA starting to
put out as showing that were just a
month or two away from month-on-month
declines in shale oil so it's been a
very long time and the market has been
kind of antsy waiting for that but I
think we're about to see it start to
turn down how does this strong US dollar
factor into what we're seeing in the oil
market particularly the volatility it's
a factor on any again big picture it's
more about the oil fundamentals I think
the dollar secondary however on any
given day and today's a perfect example
it can be
a big market mover so it's something
that we need to keep an eye on sa you
have to think that us and and and the
liftoff of rates and that whole story
okay all of this being said what does
this mean bottom line for the US
consumer the US consumer I the end-user
both individuals and businesses I think
they are going to continue to see you
know compared to what we saw in the last
three four years pretty low prices i
think the low point is the second
quarter and we start to see some
moderate uplift in a second half but
nothing crazy in other words 45 wti in a
second quarter going up to 50 54 in the
next two quarters of the year so